i recently watched chernobyl and i
wanted to watch it
um you know in high quality because i
just you can
actually yeah yeah you can buy it on
youtube that's how i watched it so you
watched it yeah yeah
i watched it on uh amazon prime and i'd
pay for every episode individually
oh no yeah i had to do that as well but
this is this is like how
done i am with not watching stuff in
like high quality that i would rather
pay
i think it's like three dollars an
episode right and it offered me did you
want to pay
1.50 for standard definition or for four
dollars for hd
i think you should be shocked as a
company whoever is in charge of the
decision deserves to be shot
right okay i'm joking that's terrible
don't get that
[Music]
that is a joke by the way this is
absolutely reasons it is a joke this is
a joke obviously
i did yeah i'm just exaggerating who who
on earth
is willing to spend like 1.50
for standard definition but not the
extra dollar it is so scummy of these
companies to do
why would you downgrade this is what i
hate if you have a product and then you
downgrade it and sell it
on purpose like no what i what i wonder
is like
they obviously know no one's gonna buy
the standard definition because if
you're buying if if you're willing to
buy standard definition
then you're gonna be the type of person
who's probably going to find other ways
to watch it rather than
watching standard definition right angry
yeah i was i was very much happy to pay
the
15 bucks to watch this whole series it
was really good yeah
but i just hate the fact that wanna make
me pay for every episode individually
and and
i like in some weird way give me a
package deal give me something well i
think it's for the people who are like
oh i watched two episodes
i don't want to watch i mean there's
there should be some kind of package
deal for it yeah oh yeah
of course the show right yeah yeah and
like i think i i've rented uh
no idea why i did this because again i
don't know why i just can't be bothered
of doing the whole dance of
some watch something online spend two
hours trying to find a link that that
doesn't give you viruses like
yeah i don't want to deal with that [ __ ]
anymore yeah like it's too stressful
and the watching movies is already hard
enough as is
i'm not i'm not doing this i'm not doing
this dancing i refuse
i think i watched borat on youtube you
watched it
on youtube i rented borat on youtube
because for some reason i wanted to
watch it again because i'm one of them i
don't know
i think i've never rented a movie on
youtube don't it was awful really
because for some reason when i rented it
i was like great
it was only in like 480p on youtube
really is it is that because it's an
older movie no i i'm pretty sure that
borrower is at least in like [ __ ] 720
or well i'd like to think
yeah like why i'm pretty sure it wasn't
in 480 i was like what is this
what is this i remember looking at the
[ __ ] did you rent the standard
version no there was only one choice it
was like three bucks yeah there's only
one
choice standard definition and then also
i just found it really interesting that
youtube actually tells you how many
views the movie has
oh really i had like 20 on youtube it
might not have been legit in that case
no it was definitely like legit really
yeah it was legit and it was just weird
because i was like this is so strange
yeah i've been i've been watching a lot
of films on youtube here in japan
because
i i find like if there's a film that's
not on netflix or something or
amazon here it's normally on japanese
youtube i don't know why it's like
like i started i started watching the
wire on youtube uh because paying for it
all
huh you paying for it all like one by
one no i'm paying like season by season
but like it because i tried to watch the
wire in the uk and it just was not
available on like
any platform that i was subscribed to
basically if it's not on netflix and
it's not on amazon prime
i'm probably not gonna watch it right
but i feel like here in japan
youtube's like the golden child there
are so many films here on youtube so
many tv series
that are blocked off when you're in like
western countries
so yeah if you're in japan use youtube
there's a lot on youtube feel like i'm
repaying my debts as a teen you know
what i mean just paying for all these
movies
with the standard definition i sit there
as i as i order my 300 yen bar at
sd quality 40p thinking old connor would
have
would have gone online and found a hd
version today no
here you go movie billion dollar movie
companies is that his three bucks
i don't have two hours to kill let's
find it i'm going to have to deal with
this
i just don't care anymore i'm just like
yeah i don't know
i value my time too much now i'm just so
busy now that the thought of spending
ten minutes to trying to find a link
if i get to the five minute mark i'm
about to give up i'm like no i'm not
watching it yeah you've lost it
like 10 years ago it'd be like day 7
still yeah
i feel like maybe it's my location
change vpn to other country to try and
get a different
google search you know what i mean like
i would do whatever it took like i
remember i tried to watch the um
the documentary about pepe and i just it
was [ __ ]
i couldn't even find a place to buy it
like it's [ __ ] impossible to try and
find this movie to watch it